one giant shark is not enough in Meg 2
the trench we can look forward to tons
of sea monsters Not only was there new
images to see but the director also
talked about the future of the film
series director Ben Wheatley who has
already demonstrated his talent for
particularly vicious films with kill
list high-rise and free fire took on the
task of directing the sequel in an
interview with total film magazine he
talked about his further Ambitions Meg 3
is absolutely on his bucket list he
believes there is still a lot to explore
in this franchise he was especially
excited by the international nature of
the movie series here people from the
most diverse parts of the world gather
to face a problem together which is a
fantastic message for the audience
however the viewers are sure to want to
see one thing Above All Else gigantic
monsters in action after all the
original book series by author Steve
Alton consists of a total of eight
volumes